I love that there's a tribute to John
Mahoney who played your father is that
the name of the bar Mahoney's bar yeah
the baby's name is John um um the dney
Dy and Niles is oh I loved him um and
Eddie oh man I love yeah you have noidea
I have but yeah he you know John John
tied a few years back and um I just
thought well we can't do the show again
without honoring John we just can't you
know and and it has to it has to begin
with the fact that John is gone and
Dad's Gone Martin's gone and so that
then I become dad you know ah my gosh
okay my makeup arst will kill me I'm a
I'm a contagious crier me too I'm going
to be fine just yeah okay um in in
Boston though um you're back there so do
you think any cheers like characters
will come in and out no I mean don't let
me down
cheers I was like that would be amazing
just one the the bar the bar is closed
we you know I mean Jimmy's decided that
know the bar went out of business for
whatever reason but I would like to see
Diane come back yeah just for one of
those reasons of of you know Fraser
being able to put something to bed to to
end up with a nice thing between them
yeah and and uh and to kind of just
ReDiscover how much because when I first
got the role the key to Fraser for me
was that he loved her with his whole
heart that he loved with all of his
being and he's and that actually defined
who he is he's been that way ever since
he just goes in wholeheartedly with
everything and that's what makes him
funny yeah oh so witty oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
gosh thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home